hello in this video I will talk about
structure and function of inter plasmic
reticulum the endoplasmic reticulum is
just like a production house of a cell
so it's just like a factory so inside
this Factory several products are
manufactured properly monitored for its
quality and stringently they are packed
properly to be delivered to specific
locations now if we talk about ER they
are a two type of endoplasmic reticulum
a rough endoplasmic reticulum and the
smooth endoplasmic reticulum let's just
talk about the rough endoplasmic
reticulum first and the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum then so in in the
rough endoplasmic reticulum
it has ribosomes attached by RIE before
you there by it is named as rough
endoplasmic reticulum now in rough
endoplasmic reticulum one of the most
important job which is done is in linked
glycosylation tag attachment to our
newly formed polypeptide so as if a new
product in the factory is produced and
that tag is attached which is a
quality-control tag or which is an
information tag that would be further
used by the quality control machinery
and can we also use to be properly
delivering it to its desired location so
that's why putting these n linked
glycosylation tag is very very important
and we would see the mechanism by which
this tag is said by other quality
control machineries inside the ER so
here is the ER lumen and outside region
is the cytosol so on the ear lumen there
is something known as doli called
phosphate now to recall is a poly
isoprenoid on the dough recall there are
several enzyme which transfers n-acetyl
glucosamine and for long it's the chain
and there is a further round of
elongation of this chain by UDP n acetyl
glucosamine and this forms a
intermediate chain of these paths after
that several residues of Manos is
attached to this growing chain
after the chin has grown to a length of
eight to nine residues of this
saccharide molecules then it is flipped
inside the ER lumen because the further
processing enzymes are found only inside
the ER lumen not in the cytosol once
inside the ER lumen the mallas residues
are also added and after that there are
blue coastal transfers enzyme which
transfers glucose on these eggs and
complete the formation of these tanks so
one miss once this n acetyl one this
once this in linked oligosaccharide tag
is ready it is transferred to a nascent
polypeptide and it attaches to a aspirin
receipting by the action of the enzyme
oligosaccharide transferase now we know
that on the ear surface on the ear
surface especially on the rough ER there
are ribosomes and the ribosomes are
sitting on the ear surface and attached
to it by rival forums now rough ER are
producing rough year surface has
ribosomes which are producing nascent
big polypeptides once the initial
polypeptides are produced they bind to a
signal recognition particle which
transfer it to its receptor the SRP
receptor now once bound to this SRP
receptor it is then further translocated
to a translocation channel through the
translocation channel the newly formed
polypeptide can enter the ear lumen and
inside the ER lumen there are protein
folding machineries known as chaperones
they are calnexin calreticulin
and VIP which is a hsp70 family
chaperone all these proteins has
different group all these chaperone
proteins has different rules in protein
folding calnexin folds the proteins into
a proper conformation and also help in
refolding
of a miss folded protein whereas p IP
hold the protein in a unfolded
conformation
waiting for the proper time to arrive
when the protein should be properly fold
now calnexin and calreticulin are
basically calcium binding lectin
selecting means they would bind to
glucose moieties or they would recognize
previous moieties so on the nascent
polypeptide there is the end limit
glycosylation tab and on the top of that
tag there are glucose residues which is
recognized by the calnexin and
calreticulin it holds the nascent
polypeptide and helps it to be folded
properly and after that a glucose adays
molecule which is a important enzyme
which removes glucose removes the last
trace of glucose from the newly
synthesized polypeptide and thereby the
newly synthesized polypeptide is ready
to be detaching from the Calvert maxims
chaperone and to be delivered to our
column now let's say the protein during
folding gets miss folded now what
happens is there are specific mechanisms
by which this miss folded protein could
be folded one such important enzyme is
glucose I transference which transfers a
glucose residue on to the top of these
tack and glucose tab attachment leads to
the rebinding of that miss folded put
protein with that calnexin chaperone now
calnexin chaperone Canada again fold it
properly and try to read le fer it pair
by inside the ER there are stringent
quality control mechanisms which is
monitor over the product quality and how
the product is delivered to the other
places now inside the ER there are
protein disulfide isomerase which helps
in formation of disulfide bonds in the
proteins not only formation of disulfide
bonds protein disulfide isomerase also
can rearrange existing disulfide bonds
and since disulfide bond rearrangement
could lead to slight change in protein
conformation so it can also change
various aspect of proteins
and thereby protein conformation now we
have talked about the functions of the
rough endoplasmic reticulum now let's
just take a look at the functions of
smooth endoplasmic reticulum the smooth
endoplasmic reticulum doesn't have these
attached ribosomes and thereby then name
is smooth endoplasmic reticulum now
smooth indeed the endoplasmic reticulum
or fer is very important for production
of membrane phospholipids inside the ACR
glycerol 3-phosphate for a several step
is getting converted into phosphatidic
acid which then further converted to
diacyl glycerol and from diacyl glycerol
it could attach to choline ethanolamine
or sailing to form phosphatidylcholine
phosphatidylserine or hospital eternal
mind which are all important membrane
phospholipids and that is then delivered
to the membranes now a CR also might
help in detoxification it has been seen
in the liver hepatocytes there are
specific molecules known as cytochrome
p450 now cytochrome p450 can carry out
various reactions and pair by could help
in detoxification of drugs and
xenobiotics and that kind of concludes
my video on functions of smooth
endoplasmic reticulum and rough
endoplasmic reticulum if you like my
video the very quick thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
please comment thank you